- I had so much fun hanging
out with Chip and Joanna Gaines
in Waco, Texas.
There were so many hilarious moments.
I mean, we really did, we laughed so much.
And then we ended up like
making a bloopers reel.
Joanna was reading the teleprompter
and she kept getting
thrown off and Chip and I
were on either side of her.
Well, you know what?
Just take a look.
- I love a good scab.
- Yeah.
- Love picking it too.
- [Cameraman] 5, 4, 3, 2.
- She hosts handcrafted home projects.
You can find him.
He hosts.
I'm just kidding, gonna find it.
You can say this part.
- No, I can't.
- If you have a real sweet
tooth, we have you covered.
If you have a sweet dose,
we got you coming, toots.
I love that Chip and
Joanna, if we wanna...
- Do it again, I'm sorry.
I was talking.
- No, and I like, liked that.
Yes, I gotta have more Zoey.
- What does that mean?
Watch this.
Do I say, watch this?
I dunno how to do it.
You say it, watch this.
- Well just say it in a normal way
that makes people wanna watch it.
You have got to watch this.
You gotta watch this.
- You gotta watch.
- Who is it?
Watch it.
- Watch this.
Okay. That's perfect.
- Now that's the kind of
promo I'm looking for.
- We're the worst.
- [Chip] No way most
of that is gonna work.